Why do people act differently when they are around other people,...
...compared to when they are by themselves?
I think it's because of the self-consciousness of the human mind.
People may not even realize it,...
...but they are afraid to show their complete personality,...
...or they just know that something they enjoy won't get them points.
People basically think that they have to change for others' acceptance.
Some people say that the reason why they act differently when they interact with others...
...is because people respond to outside stimulus.
When there is nobody around, we have nothing to react to,...
...except what we sense and what we think and feel inside.
When others are around, we experience stimulus from them,...
...whether it's visual or auditory, and we respond to that.
Other people point out that those who always tried to prove themselves to a parent...
...or tried to be like a sibling or a schoolmate when they are young,...
...tend to grow up still trying to please somebody,..
...no matter who it is.
So, they feel like they have to put on a mask when they are around others,...
...in order for people not to know how insecure they really are about themselves.